now we switch gears and talk about the
coronavirus thousands of nevada health
care workers risk losing their jobs
today if they're not vaccinated against
the pandemic that federal mandate went
into effect already and it applies to
doctors nurses even volunteers at
facilities that receive any federal
funding hector mejia joining us live
this morning hector there are probably
some concerns about staff shortages at
this point because we've already been
seeing that through the pandemic
there are and because of those severe
staffing shortages the concern is that
this mandate will only push more health
care workers away so with umc being one
of our main hospitals we reached out to
them and they told us they're actually
ahead of the curve here with 97 percent
of their staff members already fully
vaccinated and the mandate that goes
into effect this morning also applies to
nursing facilities according to the
centers for medicare and medicaid
services at last check this morning
numbers show the fully vaccinated rate
there for nursing home staff is over 83
percent it also shows nevada has the
country's third lowest vaccination rate
for nursing home residents more than 77
percent so there's still a lot of work
left to do there for contacts though the
nevada healthcare association told me
facilities are offering the vaccines
appropriately but residents hesitate to
accept them when it comes to the mandate
for workers and potential shortages one
local doctor christina madison says the
federal government is offering states
some assistance
they have these strike teams that can
come
and
augment the services of some of these
facilities especially if they do have to
let employees go because of lack of
vaccination status
so the mandate does allow waivers or
exemptions to the vaccination dr madison
adds if workers choose not to be
vaccinated they can pay to get tested
and here at umc they rolled out their
own mandate last year and after making
exemptions they told us only about a
handful of workers were left for either
suspension or termination reporting live
hector mejia live local now
something we'll be watching closely
hector thank you meantime more